wann wird dieser Tag kommen wenn
Astronauten endlich auf dem Maß sind
müssen Sie in der Lage sein dort zu
überleben und zu arbeiten das bedeutet
dass Sie Lebensmittel Wasser und
Sauerstoff benötigen eine Möglichkeit
diese lebenswichtigen Ressourcen
bereitzustellen besteht darin sie aus
den lokalen maßressourcen zu gewinnen
beispielsweise Wasser aus dem maßboden
extrahieren oder Sauerstoff aus der
dünnen maßatmosphäre erzeugen insgesamt
sind die technologischen
Herausforderungen einer bemannten
maßmission enorm aber nicht unlöst
mit genügend Engagement Forschung und
Entwicklung könnten wir eines Tages eine
erfolgreiche bemannte maßmission erleben
die Frage ist nur